don't do this now finally I am filled he
said it was like looking in the mirror
that POW that pain that's where Sapna
comes from from loss nobody saw where
look at that man's eyes like deeply
wounded soul I saw the same thing in you
that night your mother was killed what a
Myung and a half to become to stop
didn't see that coming
before rules you need to remember make
the plan execute the plan expect the
plans off the rails grow with that see
that's the thing about time travel the
more you do it the rules apply to you I
really don't think I should be fine I'm
just buying it for friends you trusted
me and I let you down to where my son
wants Chris Barry that's not my name
only need for iris to die so that you
are driven so far into the dart and I
can be there and now we're all in
trouble as I couldn't even not suck all
it's all coming together in the worst
way
five by five you kill me you become I do
you lose Sperry
holy crap everyone you kill me you
become me this is a total surprise this
is basically the finale trailer for like
the rest of the episodes of the flash
that the other shows have already
dropped so arrow release all that
Suicide Squad stuff this is just teasing
a whole bunch of what's going on about
sabotage it reveals a whole bunch of
details so there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video let's just go to
this shop buy shot you start out with
flashbacks to sabotage killing iris and
Barry realizing what it's planted so it
sounds like sabotage finally tells them
after they have this big bite here he
figures it out he comes from a time when
he wasn't able to rebound from losing
the people that he loved so you remember
like the end of season 2 Barry just like
couldn't handle it Savitt are
experienced moments like that losing the
people that he loved he even has like
his hand on iris here so it sounds like
he knew a version of iris lost them and
then went completely crazy and as he
narrates later in the trailer the more
you time travel the less the rules apply
to you so there is a bit of explaining
to do when it comes to Speed Force
wormhole aliens the black flash the time
rates but it just implies that he's the
darkest timeline version of Barry so
when he says that the rules of time
don't apply to him the same way that
zoom did because he was creating time
remnants is that what probably happened
with the philosopher's stone is that he
was just jumping all over time and space
in that how he became the first
speedster in how Jay Garrick learned
about the myths of savat are because
technically in this universe Jay Garrick
would be the oldest speedster that we've
met so far so then you learn a little
bit about what he's trying to do to stop
him in the next couple of episodes we
see Captain Cold
you see him sitting here in the Time
Vault staring at the reverse flashes
suit like oh my god how am I going to
solve this like he's looking at all of
his options is he going to try and
invoke the reverse flash that would
definitely be the measure of last resort
but I don't necessarily think that
that's how he's coming back I'll just
say spoilers for legends of tomorrow so
what happened on that show the reverse
flash was a big character that season
but it was the post season 2 version who
went through flashpoint with Barry but
because of all the stuff that they did
killing Eddie in the first season he
became a time remnant so the black flash
was after him they wrapped that story
arc
so it's almost like he's on ice now
there is no versions of reverse-flash
that we know of but I have a couple
ideas for how they can bring him back in
one of them is for Barry to take action
but I'll do a separate video about that
but I would be very surprised if we see
reverse flash in these next couple of
episodes beyond this costume here this
is just a way of invoking him without
bringing him on screen I love the
Captain Cold entrance
didn't see that coming so this version
of Captain Cold also because of legends
of tomorrow season one stuff technically
died but he's alive in the past but
because they keep talking about
time-travel breaking rules
maybe Barry break some time travel rules
and that's how they bring Captain code
to the present because in present day he
should still be dead I know it sounds
confusing when we get to that episode
I'll do a bigger explainer for how it
works because a lot of it'll just depend
on the twist that the TV writers go with
you see Joe and Irish trying to shoots
avatar here in the speed gun room maybe
he tries to jump to another universe the
way Jay Garrick talked about him is that
he went all over the place
challenging different versions of the
flash once they got powerful enough so
that makes me wonder if when he says
that he's trying to get Barry to become
him like through the tragedy of losing
iris if he's tried to do that to other
versions of very bitter the flash across
the multiverse but this is so much fun I
love the highest aspect of this Captain
Cold episode they're teasing here this
might be a plans for Argus because then
you see them looking like they're going
to try and break king shark out in this
cell here you always wondered when he
was going to come back so either this is
a very elaborate joke that they're not
going to pay off or he's going to be an
important part of how they try to fights
avatar in episode 22 but I love the Lyla
arrow crossover is it spying if we're
friends you see Tracy brand here
continuing to work on this prison for
sabotage I love the way that he jumps
into his costume too this is sort of
like the uber version of the flash ring
the costume opens up he jumps into it
midair see that's the plan
make the plan watch the plane go off the
rails then change the plan on the fly in
who else is picking up on this weird
sexual energy that's going on in this
moment right here so if you're big fan
of that kind of thing it looks like
they're throwing you a bone here I just
think it's really funny when they do
things like this you're like okay
there's very clearly something
else's going on in this scene here cisco
has that hat too though thats avatar
only wants one thing from you once he
gets it he's done with you so it looks
like he turns on killer frost too he
starts to alienate everyone so I do like
the idea that even though she's kind of
on the outs right now she'll slowly come
back around
even if she's going to be evil in season
4 she'll still have a Captain cold type
relationship with the team still a
villain one of the best flash rogues in
the comics but still is able to make
bargains with the flash work with him be
next to him without trying to kill him
HR says something about not keeping his
mouth shut so it just looks likes avatar
finds a way around all the plans that
Barry's making to stop him until we get
to the finale pushing everyone towards
these inevitable conclusions until Barry
has to find some measure of last resort
you even get a version of this Cisco
killer frost moment playing out even
though you think that you've avoided it
because they already had that fight in
the last week's episode that Cisco
narration oh my god it's all coming
together that's from another scene but
it works so appropriately when you see
them step into that snowy arena where he
lost his hand so it's like saying that
even though they've learned sabotage
secret which the future version of Barry
that we've seen before this version of
team flash has way more information it's
still not helping them the future is
still playing out the same way that it
played before just in slightly different
ways so you get a better shot of Barry
with the suit hanging up next to him
that's actually this behind-the-scenes
we finally learn what this is from then
we get another moment at irises death
from a different vantage point this is
just Joe remember we have seen this
scene from Barry's perspective several
times we've seen it from Wally's
perspective when Cisco took him to the
future there's still a couple of other
people that were there when that happen
that we haven't seen yet and then you
get that final moment you kill me you
become me so I like this confirmation
here no matter what Barry does he still
becomes avatar there is no way to defeat
him which is kind of a trick question
because yes there's always a way to get
rid of the villain problem but it's not
like previous seasons where you can just
kill someone and get rid of the problem
you can't use another time remnant the
future version of Barry that we talked
to already said that he tried that
didn't work so if you want to take the
deus ex machina route the Speed Force is
where you get into things what they've
done this season is sort of broaden the
mythology of what the speedforce is how
it works the Tracy Brand character is
studying it so I think that's going to
continue to be a big thing in season
four but it sounds like the only way to
get rid of Savitt are is for Barry to go
into the speedforce prison himself so
let me know in the comments if Barry
can't kill Salva tar how do you think
that he's going to get rid of them it's
definitely going to have something to do
with him going into the Speed Force
himself but there was a whole bunch of
trailers that I just posted there's
going to be new flash tomorrow - I have
my guardians of the galaxy Easter eggs
and I have new defenders so I'll try to
post that stuff as fast as possible
while you wait for that click here for
all those trailers from last night
Wonder Woman spider-man Home Coming and
you can click here for more brand new
flash thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight